that's aaron donald talking about bill's
quarterback josh allen
aaron donald compared him to cam newton
josh johnson the ram safety compared to
ben roethlisberger
i had forgotten peter in our current
headline at profootballtalk.com
josh allen responding and reacting a
couple of years after the fact to jaylen
ramsey once referring to allen as
trash uh alan
beat ramsey in the jaguars after that
comment but now ramsay and the rams come
to town and as an
organization this is the rams first
crack at josh allen
who's looking pretty damn good this year
you know there's a couple of things
about this game number one i knew
i knew that we would not get through the
week without one member
of the los angeles rams using the phrase
big boy pads when you play josh allen
because i think that's something that
somebody says every week
about him because he's such a huge guy
um
there's two things about this game
though i mean number one
you're gonna have the buffalo bills are
gonna have to block
aaron donald i think with two people on
virtually every snap
anybody who plays the rams understands
that that's what they're
going to have to do that requires an
adjustment
for what they're going to do what brian
dabal is going to do on offense
so that to me is one of the fascinating
parts of this game
the other thing is and i realize this
isn't totally
game related but the los angeles rams
made a decision once they found out
that you couldn't have basically you
couldn't have a lot of
freedom on the road if
they were last week staying in
philadelphia
this week playing at buffalo should they
stay back east somewhere like the niners
are doing
at in white sulphur springs west
virginia or
should they go back home and
theoretically you would say oh my god
why would you want to take two extra
five and a half hour plane rides to do
this
and i thought sean mcvay did something
very smart
he knew that if he stayed east
that for five or six days his players
were going to be captive
in a hotel and if he
flew back and got home to los angeles at
10 o'clock sunday night
then they were going to be able to have
a normal monday
went tuesday wednesday thursday
and then half a friday before going back
to the east coast and getting onto the
plane
i thought it was a very smart move
because now the players
even though they're not going out and
going to nightclubs or whatever
they can live their normal lives instead
of
being cooped up in a hotel for five or
six days
these teams are both two and oh there
are eleven two and oh teams that ties a
record one
obviously will go to three-and-oh absent
a tie a couple of 0-2 teams we mentioned
this
game briefly earlier in the show bengals
and eagles eagles are getting desperate
but
peter joe burrow doesn't care as you
said he doesn't care that the eagles are
desperate he's going to go in there and
he's going to fling it around with
confidence
and i actually think the bengals are
going to win this game because there's
that
vibe there's that that it that joe
burrow has and i feel like the eagles
currently can't figure out which
direction they're pointed in
yeah and i think you know the way that
the eagles win this game
is to put the ball in carson wentz's
hands and tell him
you're our playmaker you're our guy
you've got to make plays in this game
and who would have thought that in week
3 of the nfl season
this year that the cincinnati bengals
would come into philadelphia
with a better collectively with a better
group of skill players than the
philadelphia eagles have
i mean we could probably argue about it
especially because the eagles tight ends
are so much better than cincinnati's
but i would say overall on
sunday the group that suits up skill
players is going to be better in
cincinnati than it is in philadelphia
that puts pressure squarely on carson
wentz's shoulders to get out of his
slump
tom brady returns to denver for the 18th
time he is
eight and nine all time in denver he's
never faced jeff driscoll
in denver which should allow him to
finish his career
at nine and nine in denver i can't
imagine him playing in denver again
unless he joins
another team here's brady yesterday
talking about
whether to what extent he's going to
make that connection on a consistent
basis
with rob gronkowski well i think we all
have a lot of
things we've gotta uh you know we're
gonna be improving from the
from the time we started to the time we
finished the season so
i don't think we can be discouraged by
certain things it's some weeks it's
gonna be some guys weeks other weeks
gonna be other guys weeks and
everyone's working hard at practice to
try to find you know their spot their
role we got to figure out what works or
what combinations work or what we do
well
we don't do well and that's just part of
see the season and
um you know
i said you wish everything would be
perfect that's just not the reality of
football there's too many things to
orchestrate
there's too many moving parts um you
just got to figure out where to
to figure out ways to win games
through two games gronk has two catches
on four targets peter i
i made the point yesterday gronk is like
the guy who followed his best friend to
a new school but the friend is now
paying more attention to his new
classmates
i i don't know what's up with gronk
other than when he caught a pass in week
one it looked like he was running in mud
that may be the problem mike
i i hate to keep leaning on this i feel
like every time i've been on this show
for the last six weeks i end up talking
about the two days i spent in tampa bay
training camp
and what i saw but i'm going to lean on
it one more time
and i promise for the rest of time i
will never bring it up again
but that means you will that's what i
saw yeah i will next week of course
i lied but here's what i saw in those
you know four and a half hours watching
the books
okay there were two players on offense
that tom brady spent a lot of time
and threw a lot of balls to one is o.j
howard
the buccaneers and tom brady basically
whether it's said
unsaid whatever are trying to save the
career of o.j howard in tampa bay
he's a great football player potentially
and they want to see that potential come
out that's number one number two
i said who in the world is this number
10 who's this scotty miller you know i
had heard of him but i
i didn't know that much about him and
come to realize that
that's one of the guys in the off-season
that tom brady
really really uh began to
make a connection with and to me
scotty miller even though he's not done
very much yet
scottie miller is going to be a huge
player in this tampa bay offense so
those two
things understand this and i think
that brady basically feels look
a couple of years ago we won
the afc championship by me
going down the seam three times
at arrowhead stadium to rob gronkowski
to save the game for us
and i know that i can do that it's like
riding a bike
i'll get the ball to gronk i'm not
worried about that
i am concerned with every week making
sure
that we develop the whole rather than
just
lean on what used to be
at some point though you got to go back
to that well of what used to be or
people are going to wonder what in the
world is going on and why would the
buccaneers pay 9 million
to a guy who was on the field as a
blocking tight end
not a pass catching tight end all right
washington and cleveland getting
together both teams
one in one which one's more dangerous as
a sleeper this year
i think washington because washington's
pass rush
i think is is gold and the reason that
the pass rush didn't get home last week
is
there's not a lot of pass rushes that
are going to get home consistently
on kyler murray and i think you're going
to see
this week i i would bet
that baker mayfield watched a lot of
tape
of that game last weekend to see hmm
this is the way to evade chase young and
ryan kerrigan
and and you know and and and and they
and the really strong interior pass rush
and sweat
but the way i look at this team right
now the way i look at washington
is that they're a threat if they can
get good enough play out of dwayne
haskins
and we just haven't seen it consistently
yet mike i'm not saying it won't happen
i'm just saying
we have not seen that yet we've got
several other ont
teams playing this weekend four of them
play two-and-oh teams falcons bears
lions on two against the cardinals two
and oh texans zone two against the
steelers two-and-oh
and titans two-and-oh against the viking
zone two also the jets are owen two but
who knows how many they're going to be
owen
something i don't see them beating the
cults but these teams that are are in
that 0-2
hole is this when desperation kicks in
is it going to be the miami factor like
we saw last night peter
it's got to be desperation for the
detroit lions
um you know right now with
with matt patricia uh being
you know so far gone to respectability
loser of 11 games in a row he has
not gotten his defense together isn't
that what he was brought in to do
to build a dominant defense they've
spent some dominant defensive player
money in free agency on defense but they
haven't played well enough on defense
this even though i don't see them
beating the cardinals
i'd say this is the most desperate 0-2
team in football coming into this
weekend
yeah i agree with you as well and uh
yeah look it the teams are oh and two
for a reason
but we know that the narrative can
change quickly
it's it's one more game they've only
played two one more game from all these
teams may make us feel differently but
you know sims talks about that that
tension
after you start 0-2 there's a lot more
pressure it's palpable in the building
no one wants to be oh and three because
once you're 0-3
then your season's on the line the next
week although it may be different this
year
with that extra wild card birth maybe a
team that starts 0-3 0-4
can can do what the chargers did what
was it 1992 bobby ross's first year as
the head coach they started 0-4
and ended up somehow making it to the
playoffs